the Joe Rogan experience I would feel
like for steroids are coming I mean I
don't want to like push it but it seems
like you'd have to be I mean it's it's a
sport where it's it's built for bigger
men but I mean there's a lot of guys who
have gone through and been very adamant
that they're not and you know we get
tested we will literally like every year
I have to explain to the guy like yes
there's gonna be marijuana in my system
and that's in the rules that it says
it's okay like I have that conversation
every year and it used to be illegal
you should be illegal and we got we got
a switched believe 14 switch I brought
it up a lot I don't know if that really
changed anything but I was like look at
these [ __ ] gorillas you want everyone
here I'm vicodin and like I would
literally like all I'm saying is we
should be able to smoke weed I'm not
saying the guy should be able to do math
or any other [ __ ]
none of that like well I think we're
finally recognizing finally as a culture
that weed is not what everybody thought
it was we're never in the 50s and the
30s and thank God thank God because I
mean people were doing so much worse
[ __ ] well that's why that little Jeff
Sessions [ __ ] was driving me [ __ ]
crazy when he was the Attorney General
and he was saying we got a you know
marijuana's good people don't smoke
marijuana like right yeah you're not
hanging around with good people for now
all because good people don't want to
hang out with you exactly you don't know
what you're talking and wasn't it wasn't
a Hillary that was saying it was she was
gonna do her best to keep it illegal
yeah she had some nonsense that she was
saying to that was I don't know she
[ __ ] who knows that's crazy if I was
you and just being honest on the show
would scare the little [ __ ] out of me
because so many people listen I just be
worried that sooner or later like you
know somebody for you just show up
Hillary just shows up the show carrier
like one of the Kings they carry with
the poles on the shoulders moves the
veil impeach yes that is the one did you
see that video I put on my Instagram
with that did that dude who ya with a
Hillary head inside the body that was so
badass who is that guy let's give that
guy some props cuz that [ __ ] animation
is amazing put it put it up on on the
big screen it's like one of those things
were like how does this
got even think of this and where is he
buying his weed this is not something
that a regular person thinks of is his
name be bullcrap be ppl underscore craap
and he's got this video of this Trump
robot with glowing eyes and one
artificial leg moving and the entire
body of the Trump robot is Hillary's
giant head floating around in a vat of
liquid like a war-torn United States
soldiers marching with them yeah it's
some apocalyptic post-apocalyptic
scenario but there's all these lights
and it's [ __ ] amazing it's so dope
and Trump's body is weird and his feet
are like baby feet his hands yeah they
always get but they do their best to
just [ __ ] with that like because it
bothers him he should have never acted
like it bothered him did he act like it
bothered him I think he said something
about my hand these big hands after
they'd said it that's the thing is every
every dude knows like if a guy flinches
when you say some [ __ ] some more that
[ __ ] flinch but they're the ones who say
you don't body shame I mean well the
body shaming this programmer having
little he doesn't even have little hands
at normal hands rules don't exist
anymore has made this thing to take a
gorilla yeah if I was Trump I would hire
a trainer and just get on the best juice
- if I had abs like that I'd never wear
shirt I go to funerals without a shirt
oh yeah sorry bro you're dead but I'm
jacked in town with you put a sock on
your [ __ ] yeah I don't I don't think
Trump has little hands the regular hands
but it is a constant theme generous but
that thing that people crap guy that you
say his name beat will underscore crap
he's amazing got some great [ __ ] on his
page - that's really cool goddamn look
at that a giant kim jeong-hoon robot
there wasn't Trump just a dude every
runner good partying with that dude they
probably killed somebody together
[Applause]